[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baston c'est dangereux ici
mais tu devineras jamais ce que j'ai
trouvé qu'est ce que c'est des graines
on se ressemble tellement toi et moi vch
peur
car on refuse de laisser ce monde vous
écraser
mais ne crois pas tu puisse changer
l'ordre des choses je sais faire des
choses
j'ai tout appris sur la
pour la citadelle nous sommes de la
vermine
la citadelle veut tout contrôler ils
n'ouvriront pas leurs portes ils veulent
garder pour eux toutes les ressources
mais à cause d'eux ici on n'a plus rien
je dois trouver la clé pour débloquer
les graines les rendre fertile et met
fin à la famine pour toujours
un ring leiser
jeu s'est écrasé
je m'appelle camélias
j'espère elle n'est pas notre problème
mais elle vient de la citadelle elle
nous y conduira en route
les pèlerins
le vagabond les bandits
[Musique]
ne te fie à personne
la citadelle ne te laissera pas faire
ils m'arrêteront pas
[Musique]
si une fleur peut changer les choses
alors moi aussi
[Musique]